pierre nora bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors on le
disait le 16 mars 2014 et des habitants
de la crimée voter par référendum pour
un rattachement à la russie peut-être
pour commencer est ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer le contexte de l'époque
bonjour et le contexte de l'époque et la
crise en ukraine une crise politique qui
est provoquée par les événements du my
dames avec la déposition du président
ianoukovitch
[Musique]
l'instauration d'un système provisoire
largement dominé par ce que l'on appelle
les nationalistes ukrainiens qui
viennent essentiellement de l'ouest de
l'ukraine et qui était très largement
manipulé d'une certaine manière par des
organismes d'extrême droite et une
solution n'est pas possible de trouver à
cette crise
c'est vraiment on est au bord de la
guerre civile
d'ailleurs la guerre civile éclate dans
l'est du pays et la crimée qui est une
région qui a été cédée à l'ukraine d'une
manière totalement inconstitutionnelle
et illégitimes par le pouvoir soviétique
1954 à l'ukraine rappelons que l'ukraine
faisait partie de l'union soviétique
dont qu'il s'agissait simplement d'un
découpage administratif mais c'est une
région la crimée qui a toujours été
russe depuis le xviiie siècle
si pour ça c'est finalement pour cela
pardonnez moi je vous coupe la parole m
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov a affirmé
qu'on ne pouvait pas revenir de sucre
la crimée étaient russes que ce soit du
point de vue du droit international ou
d'un point de vue politique et moral
c'est ce qu'il a voulu dire finalement
sergueï lavrov
c'est exactement cela c'est que la
russie n'a été ukrainienne que pendant
une relativement courtes périodes de son
histoire
c'est à dire entre 1954 et 2014
est-ce que cela fonde une légitimité
dans le droit international je n'en suis
pas vraiment sûr la seule chose qu'ils
font d une légitimité de l'ukraine
intérieur pardon de la crim est à
l'intérieur de l'ukraine
c'est le principe de l'intangibilité des
frontières européennes
c'est un principe qui était justement
lui-même intangible on ne touchait pas
aux frontières européennes
et lorsque c'était à l'intérieur d'une
fédération d'états comme l'union
soviétique où la yougoslavie les
frontières des républiques fédérées va
les frontières internationales
donc la crimée s'est trouvé de facto en
ukraine et il n'était pas possible à
cette époque là ni pour les re la russie
ni pour l'ukraine de négocier cela
c'était le droit international
alors les occidentaux excusez moi les
occidentaux ont rompu ce droit de
l'intangibilité ce principe de
l'intangibilité des frontières en
acceptant l'indépendance du kosovo en
dès lors pourquoi ce que se permettent
les occidentaux ne pouvaient pas être
également utilisé par les russes
voilà le fond de l'histoire alors les
occidentaux vous nous le rappeler à
l'instant qu'ils ne reconnaissent pas
les résultats de ce référendum
comment il avait été organisée très
concrètement à l'époque comment est-ce
que ça s'était passé mais ça s'était
passé dans comment dirais-je dans la
précipitation du moment il est vrai que
ça avait été organisée en moins de
quinze jours qu'il y avait eu
différentes tentatives avant pour
changer le statut de la crimée pendant
que
la situation à kiev se détériorer et
mais ce qu'il faut voir c'est
qu'effectivement une large majorité des
habitats de la crimée était à cette
époque et le sont encore plus
aujourd'hui favorables au rattachement
avec la russie il faut également avoir
en tête un élément qui est très
important c'est que en union soviétique
tout le monde avait la citoyenneté
soviétique et ensuite il y avait une
nationalité et la nationalité ne
dépendait pas de l'endroit où l'on se
trouve et elle dépend des deux des
parents et de la transmission de la
nationalité la taille des circulations
ella maillart intéresse aux fab en
réseau fon pardon non la majorité n'est
pas à majorité russophone la population
n'est pas à majorité russophone et les
russes c'est ça que l'on ne parvient pas
à comprendre
ils n'étaient ils ont été hués craignant
que pendant est très court moment entre
l'indépendance et le rattachement c'est
à dire entre 91 et 2014
pendant cette période là tous les
citoyens de crime et indépendamment de
leur nationalité propre et il était à
plus de 60% en russe se sont retrouvés
citoyens ukrainiens points et ça c'était
inadmissible le pour eux parce qu'il
tenait à leur nationalité
c'est exactement comme si demain on
décidé qu'il n'y a plus de nationalité
française mais qu'il ya une citoyenneté
européenne et que tout le monde est
européen d'accord mais ceux qui tiennent
à leur nationalité française ils ne
seront pas contents
et là c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé donc lorsque l'on parle de
russophones
évidemment ils sont russophones
puisqu'ils sont russes alors le
président volodymyr evans qui le
président ukrainien peut compter ces
dernières semaines sur l'administration
de joe biden or c'est vrai que ce
dossier sous donald trump on en
entendait
beaucoup moins parler pourquoi
l'administration by donne est elle aussi
offensive dans ce dossier je crois que
depuis le départ bailly dunn a été un
grand grand allié de l'ukraine pour
différentes raisons d'une part parce que
c'était un moyen de créer un gain un
fossé entre l'europe et la russie par
l'intermédiaire d'une traîne mais
également parce que le président bailly
donne ou du moins son fils un père avait
des liens très proches avec les comment
dirais-je les systèmes de captation de
l'argent public par l'intermédiaire de
sociétés en ukraine c'est à dire quant à
baïda et est financé par une société
ukrainienne s'appelait bourru risma qui
faisait du commerce d'hydrocarbures et
de carburant et s'était totalement
fictif on le sait aujourd'hui un tabac
hidden profiter d'une rampe tout
simplement parce qu'il était le fils
vice président des états unis et que
c'était très intéressant pour des
affaires les oligarques les ukrainiens
d'avoir cet atout dans leur manche
et voilà pourquoi aujourd'hui je crois
que c'est le plus tôt que deux comment
dirais-je le faire profil bas
le président byden accélère sur le site
tient à l'ukraine et c'est trés c'est
très dérangeant dans la mesure où
actuellement on voit que des forces
iraniennes le kiev fort en force du côté
du dôme bas ce qu'il ya de plus en plus
de violation du cessez-le-feu que les
accords de minsk il devait être mis en
oeuvre il ya maintenant deux ans font
toujours les normands ont malgré les
engagements d'une craignant que la
france hélas
magne font profil bas et ne bouge pas
parce que vraisemblablement à l'époque
de trump ne voulait pas aller dans le
sens du président paul et aujourd'hui
ils ne peuvent pas aller ils ne peuvent
pas ne pas aller dans le sens du
président bailon merci la situation est
très très dangereuse actuellement
merci beaucoup pierre laurent pour votre
éclairage ce matin dans la matinale de
france je le rappelle vous êtes
journaliste écrivain spécialiste de la
russie